finding your purpose is easy finding
your purpose finding your passion
finding what you're meant to do is easy
and I will beat this drum until
everybody figures it out because it's
one of the most common questions that I
keep getting asked we're not taught this
in school the people that we're learning
from are not people who are living their
purpose either your purpose it comes
from your pain that's a simple answer
whatever you struggled with whatever you
felt the lowest as a human whenever you
felt the most worthless the most like
you didn't belong that moment that's
your purpose to help other people who
are currently going through that for
optimistic happy ambitious people we
usually don't like looking backwards
into the pain if you're the kind of
person watching these videos you're
probably the kind of person is pouring
into others who's loving others who's
optimistic who's trying to not think
about the rain that's happening today
right not focusing on the rain but
focusing on the opportunities and the
Sunshine to come right that's probably
you need motivation watch the top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggle
to believe myself I quit on my business
partner and the thing that saved me was
watching the successful stories of
entrepreneurs they gave me the
inspiration to keep going as well as the
strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so today let's
learn from me and my team's take on my
top 10 rules of success
enjoy
so the point is not to sit in the
previous pain
the point is to use that as Leverage
for yourself to jump into the next level
of life for you a more meaningful a more
purposeful a more intentional life
whatever you struggled with the most
there are millions of people right now
who are struggling with the same thing
they're struggling with the exact same
thing as you did
and they need your help they need your
guidance you need your wisdom they need
your story they need your hope they need
your light they need your love they need
your energy they need you they need you
to show up
that's your purpose and that will never
get old that will never get old that
will never get old every time you see
somebody
who is a younger version of you
and you can have a conversation with
them
and you can see the Hope light up in
their eyes that now they feel like
something is possible because they met
you
that's a feeling that will never get old
I'll be you know 200 years old sitting
in an old age home
still trying to help people believe
themselves more because that's what I
struggled with the most I am still
making content I am still speaking and
writing books and creating videos and
doing podcasts and shows and everything
I do is because I'm trying to help 19
year old Evan 1911 who
turned down his dream job to start a
business to make 300 a month to have no
self-belief to feel like I made the
biggest decision the worst decision of
my life
I felt like I could make the worst
decision in my life instead of taking
that dream job to do this business it
was it was hooray Euphoria for a couple
weeks and then realized oh my gosh
this is a lot harder than I thought and
I'm not making any money
did I make a big mistake
and all my friends were making tons of
money at those investment banking jobs
that I could have had
and I felt lost and I felt hopeless and
I felt like
I made a big mistake and I was working
like crazy and I was too embarrassed and
too ashamed to to ask people for help
to let people in
and I didn't believe in myself at all
that's who I love helping I love helping
humans you know I want to help humans
believe in themselves but
the the softest spot in my heart is for
entrepreneurs who are trying to get
their thing off the ground because I
remember how hard it was for me to get
my thing off the ground and
I quit there was one day that I actually
quit on my business partner
and thankfully I went back the next day
you know thankfully I didn't I didn't
fully quit all the way because I would
have regret that and I think a lot of
people do you end up quitting too soon
on your dreams
and so that's who I can kind of help
with all with all my content with all my
work with everything I do with 12 000
plus videos later I'm still doing it
people ask me how do you stay so
consistent how have you made videos
for 12 years and have not burnt out
well because I love what I'm doing
because I feel like it matters I don't I
don't love the idea of just sitting here
in the parking lot of a Costco making a
video but I love the idea that this is
talking to you that hello I'm a part of
your routine I appreciate you thank you
so much
and so you can have that too
you know whatever you struggled with
there are millions of people who are
struggling with that right now
and they don't know who to go to they
won't listen to Evan Carmichael because
I haven't struggled with the thing that
you struggled with
but to listen to you because you've been
through it
the next part becomes well who Am I who
am I to have this mission who am I to
help these people I'm still trying to
figure it out myself do you resonate
with that it's like who am I to be this
person doesn't help people I I still
don't have all the answers myself
and imposter syndrome starts to creep in
right you ever felt that
there's so many better people out there
than you and you're an imposter for even
trying
so the way to combat imposter syndrome
is two ways and
leverage both I've leveraged both and
still leverage both because I still feel
at times that I'm not good enough and
they're better people than me and so
here's the two things that I use
number one you see your growth as a
staircase
your growth is a staircase
and you you want to climb forever you
don't want to ever stop growing you
don't want to ever stop learning as soon
as you feel like you've stopped learning
and stop growing you start to really
hate your life
you always want to feel like you're
growing and learning somewhere
so look at your growth as a staircase
and when you're doing imposter syndrome
what you're doing is looking at the
people who are ahead of you on the
staircase and saying oh my gosh look at
that person they're so much further
ahead of me I suck I get why can't I be
like them why can't I be like Elon Musk
or Oprah Winfrey or Tony Robbins or
whoever your heroes are that you look up
to and respect and feel like they're so
far ahead of you
and because you're not where they are
means in your own head you can't do
anything you can't share your message
you're not worthy enough right
well what you need to recognize is
you're still on your your staircase as
well but you're not at Step Zero you're
if if Oprah and Elon Musk are at step 8
000 maybe you're at step 100.
great
but you're not at Step Zero
you've come a long way you like to look
back instead of only looking forward to
see everything that you haven't done yet
look back to see where you've come from
like oh my gosh you know what I'm at
step 100 it's nowhere close to where I
want to be I haven't figured it all out
but I've learned so much more compared
to who I used to be
then understand that
most people
who are struggling with the thing that
you struggled with
they're still at Step Zero
and you're in step 100. you can help
them you can't help them get their 8 000
level but you can help them get to step
100 because that's where you're at
most of the people who are struggling
right now are at Step Zero
and they need a little bit of help and
they need someone to believe in them
enough to help carry them to Step One
and step two and step three
it's your job to give them that hope and
to give them that momentum and you can
and the way I like to think about it is
every time I take another step up on my
journey
you reach back and you help somebody
else out who's behind you
help other people
climb on and rise on their Journey
because learning alone isn't enough we
want to feel like what we do matters we
want to feel like we're having an impact
that's where purpose comes from we all
want to wake up every day and feel like
the work that we do is going to matter
to somebody you want to feel like today
is important
I want to feel like today is important
what I tell myself at least is that
people are going to watch this video and
somebody's going to get inspired enough
to take some kind of action for somebody
watching this video this video will be
the one that actually pushes you over
the edge into action mode
whether that's true or not I don't know
but I hope it's what I tell myself and
that's how I get the meaning behind
doing the work because I'm just sitting
in my car in a Costco parking lot with
my dog here
making a video talking to my phone
but we want to feel like what we do
matters
so every time you take a step up on that
staircase it's great to have people who
are ahead of us that we learn from and
look up to but every time we take a step
up we pull somebody else up with us
and most people who are struggling
are still way way way behind you
so you don't have to have all the
answers
but you have enough answers to help the
people who are at the start
so that's one if you're struggling with
imposter syndrome you know we found our
purpose it's to help people who are
currently who we used to be what we used
to struggle with
we're trying to figure out imposter
syndrome step number one is the
staircase of growth step number two is
imagining you
sitting with yourself from 10 years ago
think about who you used to be 10 years
ago five years ago like you've grown a
lot if you're watching this channel
you're subscribed here you're into
personal development you don't want to
stay stuck you you have grown a lot you
have
if not from my content from other videos
from other books from other podcasts
you've grown a lot like hey high five
congrats it's amazing
so imagine you're gonna sit down on a
park bench
with the you from five or ten years ago
and you've got five minutes with that
person you got five minutes with former
you
think you could share something with
them that might Inspire them
you think you could share something with
them that might give them hope or some
momentum or a little bit of motivation
think about what message you might share
and when I've done this with live
audiences they'll say things like
it's going to work out
you're going to be okay
believe in yourself
you'll get through this
you're stronger than you think
you know as I as I ask live audiences
these are the things that they say on
the microphone or popped in the chat and
everybody all of these people who
at the beginning couldn't find their
purpose and struggled with imposter
syndrome now all of a sudden have
absolute Clarity and certainty with a
message they would tell the younger self
[Music]
okay great so if you are convinced that
you can help younger you
just recognize that there are millions
of people who are younger you
if you can help the you from five years
ago from 10 years ago that's what most
of the people are struggling with right
now
and that becomes your message
your purpose comes from your pain
you don't need to spend years on a
mountain
figuring it out you don't have to spend
journals upon journals upon journals you
don't need to hire an expensive coach to
help you through this your purpose comes
from your pain
whatever you struggled with is the thing
you want to help other people through
period and it will be with you for the
rest of your life
and when you can spend the time to
figure that out
and then do the exercises to overcome
that imposter syndrome that will come as
your next step
it unlocks everything
it unlocks
gratitude it unlocks purpose it unlocks
happiness it unlocks fulfillment
because what it does is give you this
well of energy
to then go off and do the scary
difficult things
to finally get out of the way of your
mind holding you back telling you that
little voice telling you you can't do
things because it's no longer just about
you it's about helping other people
and every time you can shift it from
being about you to helping others it
gives you that extra little bit of
courage to go off and do the thing
because you built to serve because you
want to help
because you got a big mission inside you
and the only difference between where
you are now and where you will be in a
year
is how much momentum and how much belief
you create in yourself to make that
Vision a reality rule number two is just
get started just start just start start
like that idea start go stop finding
reasons why you can't win stop finding
all the roadblocks that are in your way
and just get started I lost a 40 million
dollar deal when I was
because I had to have the perfect plan
and it was you know again back to fear
too afraid to launch something without
the perfect plan and I lost I lost a 40
million dollar deal because of it so
just start that thing you think you want
to do great find a way to get started on
it you want to you want to make a
YouTube channel pull out your phone and
go make your first video today
um just start on your ideas rule number
three is model success I would look at
two kinds of people to model from one
the people who've already made it in
your industry so if you're in software
look at people who are doing software
like if you're trying to be successful
on YouTube Follow other YouTubers and
doesn't mean you copy and paste but just
to get ideas to get inspiration like oh
that's how they did it and so apply that
into your business the other people
would look to are just people who you
look up to you know if you want to be a
YouTuber but you love Steve Jobs you
know there's something you can learn
from him and because you love him so
much he's your favorite entrepreneur
then you'll be able to take lessons and
apply that to your business and so
whoever it is that you look up to you
can learn from them and find a tweet to
bring that to your industry it one gives
you specific ideas so you know Bill
Gates partnership's great I'm going to
apply that and two also gives you at
least help for me it helped gave me a
lot of motivation because a lot of these
guys if you look at the heroes you look
up to Chances Are they started from less
than what you already have right now and
so seeing them do it
just gave me confidence that like why
can't I do it I can do it too and most
people's environments aren't massively
supportive most people don't have
parents telling them you're going to be
a great entrepreneur keep going and
friends like wow you're so good right
like most people I say their family
their friends like what what are you
doing are you making money is this isn't
going to work and so it can be hard to
be the the lone person betting on this
dream and everybody else around you you
know doesn't get it and so changing your
circle it's why you know these people
are behind me on my wall here in my
office you want to have an environment
of success and that is motivating as
well as a tangible kind of how-to's to
grow your business rule number four is
trust your idea that idea that you have
find a way to get started on it right
now
trust your ideas trust that if you got
this idea it came to you for a reason
it's a great idea you have to do
something about it coming up with ideas
and then writing down
you know in your notebook or email or
whatever your list of ideas you're never
going to attack that list of ideas your
your list of ideas it's just gonna build
and build and build and build and build
and grow how do you attack it by doing
so what you need to do is when you get
an idea most people what they'll do is
they'll make it bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger the idea like I'm
going to start I'm going to start a
YouTube channel oh and then from that I
can have big guests come on my show and
if I'm that I can then build a huge
email list and from that I can run my
own conferences and from that I can do I
need to make this some giant thing but
the bigger it is the more impossible it
is to start
now you need a team now you need
financing now you need all the skills
and training that you don't have and
they go I can't do that instead you
switch and just say what can I do right
now
so whether you want to start a YouTube
channel or make a song or write a book
or create a podcast or whatever whatever
idea you have start by just starting
right now don't worry about the perfect
first step because in in trying to be
perfect and come up with that perfect
first step you're doing the biggest sin
of all which is not doing anything also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is work hard
we're to smarts or where does hard work
play a factor in whether it's building a
business being successful online as an
influencer or whatever it may be
I think
intellectual ability has very little to
do with success as an entrepreneur uh I
think if you're seeing working smart
versus working hard that might be
something a little bit different but
there's I mean if being having a high IQ
was the thing that made the difference
then every University Professor would be
super rich
and and they're not and most of them
suck at being entrepreneurs
and so IQ I I think IQ Maps very poorly
actually to be to entrepreneurship when
I was in the VC business we were raising
half a million to 50 million for
companies
um if somebody gave us their business
plan and you flip to the the team part
of it and they had a PhD on their name
that would count as a strike against
them like ooh they're PhD like no Street
smarts that's not a statement yeah
that's it's a strike against them it's
against them where in the typical world
where you're where you're hiring people
like oh I got phds on my team you think
they're super smart but in the
entrepreneur world and I didn't set this
rule I was 22 years old I was just kind
of following the model that's what VCS
were saying right these guys who are in
their 60s or 70s that built giant
companies and invested in tons of
companies
um yeah he had a PhD it was a strike
against you so there's very little uh if
there is a correlation there might be a
negative one for phds or super smart
people becoming successful entrepreneurs
uh
working hard is a prerequisite for
anything in life that you want to get
um working hard is your ticket into the
game
it doesn't guarantee you're going to get
a home run it doesn't guarantee you're
going to win but you don't win without
working hard period
um there's lots of people who work hard
and never win there's lots of people who
you know
I think of think of people in my family
who who have jobs who work crazy hard at
their jobs and
don't get you know paid super super well
for it so you can work really hard and
never
go off and achieve your goals but just
working smart isn't enough
um I think what smart people do is often
find really smart reasons why they can't
win
like I can't win because of this rule
number six is choose your environment
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you where you are but
if you start hanging around that land
you start hanging around Steve Jobs and
Elon Musk and these other people uh they
will pull you into a different field of
possibility
so whether that's you know in-person
events we can't do that right now with
coronavirus but uh whether that's you
know events that you could eventually go
to whether that's books that you can
read whether that's videos that you can
watch podcasts you can listen to to
start to choose your environment so that
you're not stuck where you are is step
one and then step two to believe in
yourself is to do difficult things
a lot of the things that we want to do
we'll tell ourselves well I can't do
that I'm too afraid to do that it's too
scary it's too difficult when I say to
myself scary difficult or hard that
means I have to do it because I said it
and so what you don't want to do is
teach yourself that something is
difficult and you don't do it something
is hard and you play small
you have to lean into it that's where
self-confidence self-belief self-love
comes from because if you teach yourself
that there's something hard and then you
don't do it you're telling yourself that
you suck you're telling yourself I can't
do hard things I can't do scary things
and then the next thing that comes up
you don't do it again and the next thing
you don't do it again you keep building
this pattern where if you switch it to
say no I do scary things I do difficult
things I do hard things when it comes up
and then you do it
that's when you start to self-celebrate
Pat yourself on the back and that's
where your self-confidence self-belief
comes from rule number seven is take on
challenges and then how to believe in
oneself
by doing difficult things
right by by taking on the challenges
right so
um
even even doing this interview right
maybe you were nervous to ask or maybe I
don't remember how we got connected
initially but a lot of people
get an idea to do something
and then they teach themselves that I'm
not that's too scary I can't do that and
they don't do it
so what you're T and we do that all the
time
so there may be somebody else that you
want to book and you say oh I can't go I
can't go ask that person what you what
you're doing and not just you know you
you but people listening what people are
doing is you come with an idea
you tell yourself that you can't do it
because you're too scared you don't
believe in yourself enough and then
you're you're reinforcing that belief
so now the next difficult thing comes
along what you've done is taught
yourself that you can't do it and so
then you don't do it so you just become
this idea machine and never take an
action
the way to believe in yourself is to do
the scary thing to teach yourself that
when something is scary you do it you
jump in you say yes you move forward
because otherwise
um you're not going to live a happy life
you're going to know you're capable of
doing bigger things but never believe in
yourself to do it and so you just
photocopy the same day over and over and
over again and and hate your life and
that's unfortunately where most of the
world is Rule Number Eight Is do what
makes you proud I would equate a lot of
my fulfillment comes from the growth
that I'm getting a lot of my fulfillment
comes from like talking to you and and
making this show and and talking about
Cleveland and sharing stories and trying
to help other entrepreneurs like that's
deeply fulfilling for me that's this
isn't work for me this is like the the
second I look at my calendar it's like
oh man really I gotta talk to Jad come
on like if that's my mindset I'm out I'm
not doing those things anymore
um this is deeply fulfilling for me
balance I think is a very personal
question and will adjust throughout time
for every human so what your version of
balance looks like is going to be
different than mine than the rock than
somebody else when you hear the rock
talk about his calendar you know he
needs to work out for five hours a day
or something crazy uh and so when he's
on set he has to wake up five hours
early
to go work out and then then he'll go
and do his movie
and I think that's crazy that's not
balance for me but if you hear him talk
about being in the gym it's his it's his
Zen Zone it's his like he needs it
that's part of balance for him right so
I'd rather be sleeping I'd be sleeping
in my trailer I would not be working out
five hours you know a day but but I
don't look like the rock you know when
you get the results
um so you have to figure what balance
looks like for you
I think there are
definitely moments where you can lean in
on on gratitude and what you've got but
also want more and strive to go and get
more I think for the most part though
people need to be harder on themselves
like I'd say 95 of the time you need to
be harder in yourself and five percent
of the time you have to be more gentle
on yourself
like when you feel like you can't go
anymore when you've actually like I've
I've did my tour with a broken neck like
the second half or this is the second
the last third of my tours with a broken
neck and it wasn't when I showed up to
Cleveland I wasn't as good a presenter
as I was before I broke my neck right I
had to just sit at the front of the room
and I couldn't move for four hours while
I'm trying to help people who are in the
room
but I'm really proud of the effort
that I put in right and so all that
really matters is are you proud of you
if I had if I had to skip Cleveland like
if I was in so much pain and I just
skipped Cleveland everybody would have
understood everybody would have said hey
it's okay like dude you broke your neck
don't worry about it and if I was proud
of that then then fine
I I would do it because I had hit my Max
but I felt like I had a little bit more
just a little bit more let's show up for
Cleveland let's make it happen come on
we got one more stop we gotta like don't
skip over because I'm in Toronto so
we're pretty close yep so it's like okay
don't skip Cleveland just let's go let's
do one more and like we'll hit we'll hit
Toronto after there you go
yeah and I'm proud of that so all that
really matters is are you proud of you
you know not what other people say but
when you look at yourself in the mirror
are you proud of what you put in today
and if that means you need to lean on
gratitude one day and the other day the
next day you have to lean more into
working harder for your goals
um that's the inside game that everybody
needs to play but in general I think you
need to be much harder on yourself
because you're capable of more and you
need to push that just move the brake
line like wherever you would normally
give yourself a break
just move it a little bit
I don't don't like get all the way out
here it's just like just move it a
little bit it's an inch just yeah just
move it up just move the brake line
forward just a little bit rule number
nine is think big act small what a lot
of times people do is they have this
idea and you love the ideas like this is
this is my big idea this is going to be
my masterpiece and it's just gonna
change the world and it's so exciting
and it's so easy to live in that future
world of how exciting everything's going
to be
but the more you live there the bigger
the idea gets and then you realize oh I
need a team and I need to have all these
people and then to make that happen I
need to raise a million dollars and you
just make it bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger that it becomes
impossible to ever actually do and then
you get depressed like I can never go
out and do that like who am I to go out
and do that
where what I encourage people to do is
have a big goal have a big dream you
need to but then act small you're
thinking big and you're acting small so
whatever it is that you want to do find
one small way to just get started so to
start a YouTube channel you don't need
to have an editor and a researcher and a
production team and be graded all of
this stuff like just do a video and
expect it to suck and be okay with it
sucking and then just suck a little bit
less the next day like
people will make a video and then or
they'll make their first product or
whatever it is and it will suck and then
you know they know it looks good they
know that if they watch a big YouTuber
or they see somebody else's product they
know like well that's what looks good
and I can't make that and so I suck and
then I'm gonna try again it's taking the
big vision and and living there and
loving it but finding the smallest
possible action to get started today
know that it's gonna suck and just keep
the continuous momentum going every
single day and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is aim for impact success is a is a is a
habit success is how you showed up today
so for me success is that I put my best
effort in
right so as an example today all day I'm
just doing interviews right I had like
four before you and another six after
you and my goal today is to create an
interview that I'm going to be proud to
show my grandkids
right I want my grandkids hey hey
grandkids listening like I want I want
this interview to be the one that I I
gave my best to and that my grandkids
are going to listen to that is Success
at the end of the day it's me saying I'm
proud of myself for what I did not
hitting some goal so learning to tie
yourself like what is success hitting
two million subscribers you know hitting
I didn't even want to celebrate I didn't
even care because the success for me
Isn't hitting the million subscribers
success for me is is showing up today
and having an impact
and so that's what I'm that's what I
celebrate and pop myself in the back for
every day more than did I get a certain
result
is one of the most important and least
understood things that I think you can
do especially as an entrepreneur we've
all heard the expression find your
passion find your passion you got to do
what you love and from all the videos
that I've done and all the people that
I've studied and profiled whether
they're entrepreneurs innovators
athletes recording artists like whatever
they are the number one rule that they
all have in common is find your passion
when I get asked you've studied all
these people what's what's the most
common thread that's it find your
passion you have to be doing the work
that you love
but how do you do it how do you find it
because most of the time we know what we
don't want right you know the life that
you don't want you know the people who
you don't want to be hanging around
you've been at some job that you do not
enjoy we typically know what we don't
want but we haven't done the work or
been given the tools to know what we do
want and that's what I'm going to cover
in this video for me I love helping
entrepreneurs I think your purpose comes
from your pain right so whatever you
struggle the most in life is what you
want to help other people through you
are built to serve so your purpose your
passion becomes a part of that will
definitely be in service to other people
somehow
it's not enough for it just to be about
you you have to be doing other things I
just came from doing some squats I feel
a little out of breath was amazing I
love this this is the best and so your
purpose comes from your pain your person
your purpose is to help other people
through something especially what you
went through yourself the passion
component though is actually enjoying
the work to get people to the other side
so for me I love helping entrepreneurs
I struggled a lot in my early days as an
entrepreneur and
I'm I'm basically trying to make the
world of 19 year old Evans who are
struggling not struggle as much as I did
and I'm a visual learner so I'd much
rather see visual content than anything
else YouTube did not exist when I was
getting started and so I'm trying to
share whatever wisdom I have share the
lessons from other successful
entrepreneurs so that all of the 19 year
old Evans out there can learn and can
improve and get better
I have a process that I call the passion
process and if you go through this
process it'll help you identify your
passion
and give you a lot more light love
energy and money you know because we got
to make money as entrepreneurs so the
passion process is this if you want to
go through it make a list of all the
things that you've done to help other
people
especially the kind of people who who
are who you used to be like make a list
and I went through this process and
built a serve I did this with my wife to
help her find her passions this is where
it was birthed but if you just make a
list of all the things that you enjoyed
helping people with like you you got
them a result you're so happy that they
are now in a different spot because of
what you did like what did you do where
you showed up and you helped somebody
with something and just if you want to
pause the video you can if you want to
make a mental list just all the things
that you've done to help other people
okay
after you have that list
then write down or just circle the ones
that you actually enjoyed the process of
doing as opposed to just the end result
this is where we get stuck this is where
entrepreneurs get trapped okay we enjoy
the end result of what we've done but we
don't enjoy the process of doing it how
many times have you helped somebody else
out because you're a good person because
you're built to serve because you love
that person or even you see yourself in
that person and you just wanna you just
want to help
and you're so happy that you helped them
but you didn't actually enjoy the work
that you were doing and that's the key
difference the result has to be there
that you help somebody of course and the
thing that will make you light up come
alive love doing for the rest of your
life is the actual work you're doing you
love to so to bring it home like that's
some great Theory awesome
in my example
the example that I use in in built to
serve in my book is I love helping
entrepreneurs like I want to see you in
I every day I wake up and I try to
figure out what else can I do to try to
help entrepreneurs win how else can I
help the 19 year old Evans of the world
out there get their business off the
ground
and if you were to move your office say
you're going from a home office to you
got your first office it's like wow you
got your first place amazing and you
needed help moving I could help you move
and I would be so happy to see you in
your new office
the problem is I don't enjoy the process
of moving I don't want to unplug
computers and pack them in boxes and
move desks and sure it might be a fun
workout but I don't get lost in the
process of that right I don't love it I
love the end result of helping the
entrepreneur but I don't love the
process of getting the entrepreneur to
that result and that's the key
difference that's where most of you will
get trapped you love the end result and
feel like what you're doing matters and
is important great and you get that
little hit at the end like yes I helped
that person but did you actually enjoy
the process of you doing the work and if
not that's what we need to revisit most
entrepreneurs are doing too much of the
work that they do not enjoy just trying
to get to the result now not everything
you do is going to be amazing not
everything that you do is gonna is gonna
fill you up with joy and passion a lot
of running a business does suck and you
have to do things you know accounting
and taxes and legal stuff it's not stuff
that makes me come alive and I find
joyous but your goal as an entrepreneur
needs to be to spend more time in that
zone of Genius where you do actually
love it and at the beginning beginning
you know maybe it's 50 50 but hopefully
as you build and scale and grow and
learn more about yourself you can shift
the percentage of how much you do that
is in your zone of Genius that you love
doing versus what has to get done to
grow the business right and as you build
and scale and grow that's hopefully
where team comes into place to handle
all those things that have to get done
that you don't enjoy doing so if you
make your list of all the ways that you
have helped people if you have no idea
what's my passion you have no idea make
a list of all the things that you have
done that you've you've enjoyed the
result of helping somebody what have you
done to help people then Circle the ones
where you actually enjoyed the process
so I don't want to help entrepreneurs
move and pack boxes even if it leads to
a great result I want to do something
that I actually enjoy the fastest way to
change your habits is to change your
environment
you ever notice how when you're in a
different environment maybe you go on
vacation maybe you go to an event or
seminar
you start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy but if you've ever
been away and you notice that you've
picked up some new habits why well
because the environment demanded it
because everybody else was doing it
because it was so easy natural
comfortable to do that that that's why
you do it too and so if you want to be
able to switch your habits quickly you
change your environments now you may not
always be able to go on vacation or go
to events or seminars those are options
but it starts with you figuring out well
what are
the habits that you want to develop who
are the people that you want to be
around and when you are around those
people you will start to think
differently which will lead to you
behaving differently when you see other
people doing it you're going to want to
do it more when it's in your environment
more you're going to want to do it more
too this morning I was talking to a
YouTuber big YouTuber bigger than me
more subscribers than me slightly
different Niche and I remember meeting
him in California
a couple years ago and one of the things
he was struggling with was staying
consistent and I'm very consistent and
one of the things I was struggling with
was staying healthy while I was on the
road and we're having dinner together
and he was eating
super clean he was eating fish and salad
and I probably had a burger or something
fries and
coming away from that what I realized
was
whoever is more confident wins and when
you're around other people whoever's
more confident in the habit that they
have will be the dominant habit that
both of you end up picking up so if we
were hanging out together more here's
what would happen I would become a lot
healthier in my eating and he would
become a lot more consistent in his
content because we'd be inspired by each
other because he'd see me working with
make my videos and he'd feel bad that he
was making his and he'd have to go and
start making his and I see him eating
healthy all the time like man I should
be eating healthy and they would force
me to do it as well that environment
switch would allow us to create much
better stronger habits so now you got to
be careful about the kind of people who
you're hanging out with and if you look
at the people you've got right now
around you chances are
they're keeping you stuck they're
keeping you small they're keeping you
where you are and you're probably
pouring into them right you're the one
giving them love giving them
encouragement giving them support
pouring into them you're taking your cup
and pointing to them and it's great and
it's and you should keep doing that and
it's amazing and it's it's fulfilling
but who's pouring into you and who's
making you get to the next step uh
because if you don't have that you're
gonna you're gonna continue to stay
small or just have slow growth compared
to where you could be so how do we get
some practical steps okay that's great
what do we actually do how do you start
making that change happen well the first
step is to figure out what is it that
you want to get better at you know what
area of your life or business do you
want to be better at is it you want to
stay more consistent on your habits you
want to you want to learn how to make
money you want to have a better
relationship you want to take care of
your health like what is the thing that
you actually want to get better on
getting Clarity on what that thing is
two is to then surround yourself as much
as possible with
with content not even people because it
could be great to say hey awesome hang
around Joe dispense all the time and you
will you will become better you will
meditate more you will solve your
awesome but you don't know Joe dispenser
and he's probably not taking on students
right now or mentees right or Elon Musk
or Oprah Winfrey whoever right you don't
know them and so that's not a practical
answer but you can hang around their
content
it's why I make these videos every day
because if every day there was a new
video for you hopefully it lifts you to
bring some of the best experts in the
world the people that I find inspiring
and learn from to share their message
every morning you don't have that person
in your life but there's videos for you
so step two is step one we're figuring
out what is it that we want right where
do we want to improve and get better
step two is who are the people who are
who are living it who are preaching it
who are living it who actually inspire
you and there's so many different people
out there who are doing it and everybody
has their own way I like to say that you
know an Aaron Thomas is going to yell at
you through it and Oprah Winfrey is
going to hug you through it but they
have very similar messages
whoever style you connect with the most
have that more consistently in your
environment follow them on Instagram
subscribe to them on YouTube put their
quotes on the wall around you create
your own environment of the people who
make you feel like you want to do more
who inspire you to step out of your
comfort zone and take on those new
habits that you want to actually adopt
right so you're creating a new
environment for yourself without having
to go live with Joe dispenza or Elon
Musk or Oprah Winfrey
okay so I call them aspirational mentors
and and that can be fundamental and
that's where most people need to start
because you have access to their books
and their videos and their content you
have that access right now and that can
make a big shift in you if you start
surrounding yourself with it every day
and then step three is to is to get more
in-person connections and this is more
time consuming and more challenging and
harder to find the right fits but
can make a big shift as well in your
life so I don't want to only rely on and
it's why step two was actually having
just content that you're learning from
but step three if there's people that
you're learning from do they have an
event do they have something coming up
can you hang around people who are
like-minded who are also taking on
challenges I'm doing a challenge right
now inside my movement makers program
where Movie Makers is For Thought
leaders who are trying to get to the
next level with their content and break
through and have a greater message and
reach more people
but a lot of people haven't been as
consistent as they should have because
they're the only ones doing this who
don't know anybody else making content
their family thinks they're crazy like
why are you making another video they're
not seeing results that they don't have
a peer group they don't have anybody to
connect with and talk to and
this can relate to any goal that you
have movement makers is just for kind of
thought leaders making content but
whatever goal that you have if you're
the only one that you know who's doing
it it's really hard to stay consistent
on it so our Movie Makers challenge is
every month we have a challenge where
you have to make a lead magnet for your
business a solo video and then three
collaboration videos with other people
in the group so it forces you to start
making content and for a lot of the
members this is the most consistent
they've ever been now in making content
because one they're doing it together
you feel like you're doing it with other
people even though a lot of the content
that you make
um outside will still be separate from
the members you're not doing a business
together but it feels like they're
connected we're taking on this challenge
together and then in the collaboration
videos you're you're connecting with
people you're doing interviews with
people you're you're sharing your
thoughts and feedback it's not just you
talking to a camera in the car with your
dogs by yourself anymore
matters it really matters so getting
some kind of support group connecting
with other people who are on the same
Journey going to seminars or events of
of humans that you can talk to and
connect with who are doing the thing
that you want to do because the more
that you're around those people the more
you're going to stay consistent on the
habits that you want to build so using
that three-step process can absolutely
change your life
it's it's entirely possible and if
you're watching videos like this you're
you're already on the growth mindset
Journey right you're already into
personal development you already know
you want to do more and serve more and
help more and this helps you elevate
yourself to the next level because you
are probably the most
ambitious person that you know that
you're hanging out with and and that's a
great place to be because you're serving
and helping but it also sucks because it
limits your growth of what you could
become where if you can one clearly
identify what you want to change what is
the Habit that you want to take on where
are you not satisfied anymore in your
life not beating yourself up and saying
you suck but like the next level of
growth that you want to accomplish
yourself and then two following people
just through content who are living that
message who are who are not just
speaking it but living it who when you
watch their their videos you actually
get inspired to go make a change in your
life who are those people subscribe to
them follow them every day watch their
content read their books put their stuff
up on your wall as a reminder you're
creating a new environment for yourself
and then three is actually connecting
with humans joining a group like Movie
Makers or something else going to events
where your your tribe is at so that you
are not alone doing this journey feeling
isolated and like you don't belong make
those three changes it will change your
life the difference between where you
are now where you could be is just the
consistent habits that you're putting in
you know this I know you know this now
it's about taking the actual action to
stay consistent on those habits the
fastest way to shift your mindset in a
positive direction is to choose to show
up with love if you're stressed out if
you're fearful if you've got anxiety if
you're low on energy just shift just
tell yourself I'm gonna show up with
love and see how that moves you forward
in a positive direction otherwise you
get stuck you stay stuck because you
listen to the voices in your hand as to
you're not good enough why I can't do it
and everybody's doing better than you
and and so on where when you can choose
a show with love it just negates all of
that so let me share a couple examples
that I've used it in my life and
hopefully it applies to your life as
well to help you get the momentum that
you need so scenario number one is when
you're stressed out when you are
overwhelmed when you're doing something
scary or you're in doubt and you come up
with all these reasons why you can't do
something so for me it's staying on
stage you know going on stage doing a
big presentation even making these
videos every time before doing something
that I want to be good that I'm worried
about that I might disappoint somebody
the procrastination sets in the fearful
thoughts set in because I wanted to be
the best that I've ever done
my biggest fear is still disappointing
people and instead of listening to those
thoughts and how it may show up is oh
um my message isn't good enough oh I
don't know what gear to use maybe not in
my case for that one but what prevents
you from doing it there's logical
reasons but really just fear talking
where if you can
decide you know if I'm making this video
is it my best video of all time maybe I
want it to be is it likely not but I'm
trying
and the way through let's just show up
with love like I love you I love you
thank you for being here thank you for
investing in yourself thank you for
putting putting goodness out into the
world you know I make these videos
because you can reach people that I
can't your business your heart your soul
your your beliefs what you've been
through your story can touch people and
change the world in a way that I can't
and so if I can be a little bit of a
push motivation whatever to help you
start doing something that makes me
happy it fills me up knowing that that
what I'm doing matters is important
right so show up with love that's all I
have to do don't worry about it being
the best video of all time just show up
with love don't worry about it being the
best speech of all time just show up
with love remember why you're doing it
it's another version of it right like
why are you doing this thing but not
from an extra pressure you know if you
if you feel over pressured to be great
then that can be debilitating to the
point where you freeze a lot of
procrastinations you're just afraid to
do the thing and so choose to show up
with love I love this person I love who
I'm trying to help even if you don't
know them right some of you are watching
this video I've never met you before
thank you for being here
even if you say I love you even mentally
I love this person I love I love my eyes
I love my customers even if you haven't
met them yet it it rewires you it just
makes it so much easier try it like what
are you procrastinating on that you want
to get done that you know you want to
get done not that that you don't want to
do but you want to do it's part of your
goals it's your Ambitions that you hope
one day you could be that person right
what are you procrastinate on and just
flip it from having to be perfect to
saying I love these people I'm gonna
show up with love and watch it just
shift you so you can actually start
taking some momentum it's a huge huge
huge huge huge thing for anything that
you're procrastinating on that you're
afraid of so scenario number one uh the
things that you're afraid of scenario
two is is people and specifically the
people who are who are negative the
haters that we might call it I don't
actually like the term haters I don't I
don't think there are haters I think
there's just people who are in a lot of
pain you know I think if somebody is
highlight of their days to show up and
leave something negative on your website
on your YouTube video on your social
media accounts whatever they're in a lot
of pain you know I think people are
built to serve we are good we want to
help we want to we want to contribute
and so somebody that's everybody like
everybody wants to serve so if somebody
is showing up with negativity in their
heart thrown at you when they've never
even met you before
uh why would they do that well they're
in a lot of pain
hurt people hurt people
and so
a lot of times we get uh emotional you
know we don't like seeing those negative
comments I don't like seeing negative
comments even on a channel like mine
where it's only positivity I'm not
making bash videos on people
if somebody's gonna show up to a Channel
about positivity and leave negative
comments how how much in pain do they
need to be and to do that and even just
seeing it like that already starts to
shift it but what if you were to say I
love this person like how would you show
up if you love that if you loved your
hater
not because it fuels you to go prove
them wrong and be better but
feel bad for them not sorry for them but
just have empathy for them and say you
love them like if you love this person
how would you show up differently
instead of allowing that comment that
they left on your video to ruin your day
to me to maybe make you never post again
to get into a fight or debate or respond
uh to them you know and try to win win
the battle instead of that if you
actually said hey I love this person
even if you don't like you don't know
them you might think well that's
ridiculous I don't know this person I
get I know I understand this is not your
mom coming on your YouTube channel and
saying that you suck it's some random
stranger you've never met and maybe you
don't even know who they are and you
can't see their name and their profile
pictures of cartoon right or soccer
player uh so that's fine but even if you
just say I love this person how would it
change if you love this person and watch
it shift you watch the chemicals and you
start to shift towards you now being
more proud of yourself if you show up
with love it allows you to have the
courage to be the person who you want to
be who you're proud of like when you get
some negative comment and then you
respond in a really snarky way or you
show up somebody slights you some way
somebody cuts you off in traffic I'm in
my car right now somebody cuts you off
in traffic and you have to you have to
catch up to them and give them the look
or cut them off or Blast Your Horn you
know if you actually thought about that
are you ever proud of yourself
are you proud of yourself in those
moments like if you reflect back and say
see what you did in reaction are you
proud of how you showed up probably not
right probably not at least I'm not when
that happens and so the way through it
is is to show up with love like even
just tell yourself I love this person
I'll practice it with random people on
the streets you know like I'm walking
down the street and somebody comes by
and like I love this person just as a
mental exercise of practice how do you
show up instead of just being head down
ignoring them you know looking at your
phone maybe give them a smile it feels
really weird especially as an introvert
shy person
um I don't go up and say hi to people
but it's a good practice to get into but
especially for the haters like number
one and two one is again you're afraid
you're stuck you're overthinking
stressed out and number two is you're
you're also afraid but of people's
opinions and specifically the negativity
that's out there what they do is they
prevent you from taking action it keeps
you out of momentum
you're just stuck in fear Zone instead
of creation Zone and so the opposite of
fear is love
it's not hate like the opposite of Love
isn't hate the opposite of Love is fear
and so it allows you to get out of the
fearful mindset and into a loving
mindset which is not just
fluffy it's not it's not
you know what I'm saying it gives you
into momentum mode moving from Fear To
Love allows you to take action and
that's what makes it super practical
so
have love even in your own mind for who
you're trying to serve and what you're
trying to create have love for any
negativity any people who are who are
criticizing you they're not haters
they're just people in a lot of pain and
show them love and watch how it shifts
you into momentum and in the third
scenario is loving for yourself
a lot of times you seem to love
ourselves more so the first two are
loved that are outwardly pointed right
out toward our customers or the audience
towards people who are disagreeing with
us or disrespecting us or hating hating
on us but the third one is just
self-love more self-compassion self-love
love love that you showed up today love
that you decided to watch this video
today love that you're you're fighting
to chase down your goals and your dreams
even in the face of not getting a lot of
results or not being where you want to
be you know you're you're probably not
where you want to be right now and maybe
you're not proud of the week that you've
had or the day that you've had or the
month that you had or the year that
you've had that you could have done
better you should be you should be
further ahead right has you ever thought
has that ever popped into your mind
so self-love again allows you to get
into momentum so what can you be proud
of yourself for so love that you showed
up love that you're trying today love
that you're watching this video right
now love that you're making another
attempt even if you fail that a million
other times you're trying again like
love that love that you're starting love
that you're learning love that you're
adapting love that love that you're
gonna put your fourth your best shot
this time and maybe this is the one that
actually sticks like love that about
yourself as opposed to just beating
yourself up and say oh well here I am
again you know another thing that's not
gonna work because again that keeps you
stuck
all of this does two things
it allows you to actually build the
thing that you want to build
right it allows you to be proud of
yourself it allows you to start getting
more results start getting closer to
your dreams because you're showing up
with love instead of fear right love is
the opposite of fear and two it allows
you to have more fun along the way
so that you're not just constantly
stressed out of jumping from one problem
to another problem to another problem to
another problem because entrepreneurship
is a lot of problems right
you have a lot of problems running your
business a lot and and we're
professional firefighters just
constantly putting up fires so if you
can do that with love
it's a lot more fun
this is a lot more fun
so it allows you to be more productive
and effective and it's a lot more fun
and so I think love is a strategy love
is a secret ingredient and it's
something that I need to I'm not perfect
at it I need to constantly remind myself
of it this video is a great refresher
for myself as well and the more that you
can have that as a reminder in your
daily environment as a as a mantra as
something that you live your life by to
choose to show up with love for your
customers for your haters and for
yourself
you can start to embody that even five
percent of the time entire life changes
self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
it's too hard it's too difficult it's
too scary
most people let you off the hook
people around you will say yeah yeah
it's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
could have done it you know like that's
the worst feeling in the world that you
could have done something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and padding on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry you can't
see we had like you see some here behind
me it's like look at see that mountain
of snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rucking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
there's no path to walk on and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like oh I could look out the
window and say ah so much snow I'm not
gonna do that I'll do it when there's
less snow you know and then the next day
there's less snow there's still snow in
the next it's still snow and then all of
a sudden you just gave up on the Habit
right like you let yourself out the hook
to say I'll do it tomorrow and then and
then you never do it and then the
habit's gone and that's what you're
teaching yourself this is why it leads
to Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
going to do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so this is snow it's up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious no like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me uh I
don't have to walk through that much but
but up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters
through this thing
and initially my thought was oh man why
is there no path why is nobody shoveled
this why has nobody still blow this like
can I get over there I got a backpack on
I'm rocking I'm sweating like crazy I'm
already exhausted now I gotta go through
this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth happen off the hook so it's okay
go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snope to
your knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you look outside and
see the snow and not go just by default
not even catching the the conversation
with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you know I
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
you know I'm walking through I'm
freezing uh I'm taking one kind of giant
step at a time snow is getting all
through my boots all down my legs I I
almost slip and fall I have a coffee
that I that I picked up uh it's dripping
all over the place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best
let's go let's go Evan you got this man
let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating the path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so that now they will have not an easy
time but an easier time of crossing the
same path
so they can get across
so it's going to serve us
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships in your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you can be more
likely to actually do the thing because
you've been training and conditioning
yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not they're usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore if you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of other
people you will never do anything great
you will never live your great life
because somebody always has a plan for
what you should be doing with your life
you will never please everybody it's not
possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step RIP by
Brick one snow storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life
you deserve a great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and hard honestly I think
we're all thinking small
you're thinking small I'm thinking small
we're all thinking small compared to
what what we're capable of and I think
we've been conditioned to think small
we've been conditioned by our upbringing
our family our our parents our guidance
counselors our teachers our
we've just been conditioned to think
small because we're learning about life
from people who
also never thought big and so
because we are products of our
environment we have conditioned
ourselves to think the same way is it
the people in our environment and if
you're not happy with your environment
and your environment is not around
around big people who've done amazing
things or thinking big then you will
stay stock thinking small as well what I
love about Naveen Jane is that he thinks
big you know the first time I found this
content there were three people who
I get recommended all the time you
should do a top 10 on this person you
should do an Express on this person you
should profile this person and there
were three people who for the first time
upon first consumption of their content
really blew me away one was Denzel
Washington
uh if you have not seen Denzel
Washington you should go watch his top
ten he his backup plan for his life was
being a minister uh and he is a fire
presenter I just kind of a lot of times
we do actors it's really hard to get
anything good out of the interviews that
they're doing uh but Denzel Washington
is a whole other animal so he really
blew me away the second was Priyanka
Chopra uh who had just amazing set of
interviews and super intelligent bright
woman and the third was Naveen Jane
where I'd like no idea who this person
is you should do Naveen Jane great go
look him I was like oh my gosh this
guy's amazing I want more Naveen Jane in
my life I think that's a great sign you
know like when you find people like that
even if you've never met them and up
until this year I had never met Naveen
Jane The Good Fortune I just recently
have him on on my channel to do an
interview and a collaboration but up
until that point I'd never met him
before and
when you find the people who make you
think bigger who make you feel more
confident to make you feel more bold
you around them more
this is my solution right I am trying to
hang out even if it's just virtually
with the people who inspire me to want
to play a bigger game you know either
those three people I haven't met Denzel
Washington
yet I haven't met Priyanka Chopra yet uh
and up until you know this year I hadn't
met Naveen Jane yet but I can still be
inspired by them I can still learn from
them I can still look at their content
and they can still push me to become
better
and I think
a lot of us stay stuck and stay small
because it's so
good to feel important
and we end up being the big fish in a
small pond if you're watching this video
you are probably the one that's pouring
into
everybody else you're probably the most
optimistic person in your circle you're
probably the one who cares the most
about the people around you you're
probably doing the most for the people
in your circle and you're the one people
come to and say Hey how do I X you know
how do I grow how do I get better how do
I you know you're the one that's
advising and helping and pushing other
people maybe pushing them too much
that makes sense maybe you're maybe
you're pushing some people too much but
you're the most optimistic most
ambitious person in your circle probably
that's great in a sense and that you can
pour and give back and help others along
the way but who's pushing you
you know if you don't have somebody
pushing you to be better to be stronger
to be greater to be more ambitious to
think bigger than you probably won't
like if you
it's really uncomfortable to think
bigger and if you don't have somebody
inspiring you pushing you helping you
then you probably stay stuck and that's
what we need to change and so the that's
a message for you but it's a message for
me equally so and so step one in doing
that I think is just changing the
environment to be around the people who
do inspire you and chances are most of
the people who do inspire you are not
not people who have you have direct
access to and not people who are taking
on an intern you know Warren Buffett's
not taking on an intern to go live with
him for a year as far as I know
so how do you do it well the easy way is
through content
I've learned so much you've been
inspired so much by just amazing people
through the content on my own channel
like I make these videos for me because
I need them because I need to believe
more in myself and then I share that
with you and thankfully enough of you
like it that I can make it a business
and hire a team and continue to make
even more content because if it was just
me then it'd be a lot fewer videos
coming up and a lot less profiles and a
lot less content
so being around the people and when you
find people who really speak to you who
really get you going who's like yes this
is exactly what I need then
be around them more subscribe to their
channels buy their books listen to their
podcast be around them more if they're
speaking an event go to the event
because it'll push you to reach another
level and this is why it's so great to
have so many people now I'm I'm
passionate about helping bring
new people onto the to platforms like
YouTube and getting their message out
there because some people
[Music]
will push you through things some people
will hug you through things everybody
has their own lens and you'll connect
with people in a different way so you
look at a Eric Thomas so you look at a
Jocko willink or you look at uh Andy
frisella
who are going to be very in your face
cut right to the truth no BS no excuses
no wiggle room like get up and go chase
down your life now it's a hard push they
may be yelling at you they're very
intense it's a hard push forward and
there'll be other people like Oprah like
um brene Brown like Dave Meltzer who
have a different approach it's a much
softer approach they'll hug you through
it you know some people will push you
and yell at you to get through it and
some people will hug you through it a
lot of times the message is exactly the
same you know Oprah's message is very
similar to Eric Thomas's message the
difference is the delivery
Oprah will hug you through it and Eric
will push you through it and it really
just depends on what you need there's no
right or wrong it's just what do you
need and when you find the people who
give you what you need just be around it
more be around that more because no
matter how much you watch
one video
the impact will wear off right like
you're waking up tomorrow
the same person you were almost
yesterday maybe a half a percent better
but you could be you could watch this
video get all inspired be like yes all
right I'm gonna chase things down
amazing let's go and you have energy for
a few hours for the day but then you
wake up tomorrow and and that energy is
gone right has that happened to you that
energy suddenly is not there anymore you
don't feel as bold as courageous or
ambitious as you were yesterday why what
happened
it's not that there's nothing wrong with
you that's just normal
because you got an injection into your
environment that took you to another
level and then it it fell off
because there was no consistency in the
environment so you are where you
consistently do so whatever you want to
accomplish whoever you want to be to
consistently surround yourself with
people like that
because you're not getting enough in
your home environment your home your
environment now your life has been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are it's allowed you to get to where you
are right now amazing and if that's
where all you want to be awesome
congratulations you've done it you've
you've hit the jackpot but if you want
more
then your current environment is not
designed to help you go and get more and
again I'm talking to myself just as much
as I'm talking to you like say these
words out loud it's like what changes do
I need to make to my environment who do
I need to be hanging out with more
either in person or just through the
video content to make me want to push
more be more courageous save save
Bolder things and have bigger
aspirations and goals and dreams and and
take Boulder action towards
accomplishing them
right makes a big big difference and so
if you want to accomplish something if
it's business success or mindset success
then if it's just thinking bigger then
if you love Naveen Jane be around Naveen
Jane more
watch all his interviews and then listen
to any podcasts that he does and I did
one on my main Channel we'll link that
up at the end of this video you can go
watch if you want if you want to improve
your health and fitness and you're tired
of you know being on an Oreo diet okay
you can make a choice and a decision
that I'm gonna I want to be this person
I want to be the person who works out I
want to be the person who takes care of
my body takes care of my health and
energy and that's awesome as a decision
but you need the environment to support
you and so now if you're subscribing to
health channels if you're following
people on Instagram who are working out
and take care of their bodies it will
make you want to live a healthier life
one of the ones that I love watching is
Tom bilyu and his health Theory show
where he's interviewing experts around
health and every time I listen I was
listening to one this morning every time
I listen watch it makes me want to be a
little bit healthier
you know the more that you're around
that kind of stuff the more you will
take on the mindset similarly if you're
injecting poison like if you're around
negative people or you're consuming
negative content and that's most of the
news and most of media to be honest is
mostly negative if you're surrounded by
negativity constantly and you're you're
watching negative videos and reading
negative news constantly you will be a
lot more negative you'll be a lot more
scared you'll be a lot more scarcity
mindset you'll be a lot more afraid
you'll be a lot less positive and
ambitious because that's what you're
feeding into your mind so be very
careful about now designing and
Engineering your environment your
environment has happened to you
you know you've had some control over it
but it's it's mostly happened to you
and now you can with intent change it
to be more positive if you had to ask
yourself if I wanted to surround myself
with the most positive encouraging
inspiring
people who will make me more courageous
bold and ambitious
who would those people be what would
that environment look like
and then make a choice
change it
change who you subscribe to change what
you're listening and watching
unsubscribe from all the channels that
make you feel worse about yourself
change your physical environment what
what clothes are you wearing what do you
put on the wall around you what's your
background on your cell phone and on
your computer you start to change it and
when you change your environment
it'll Force the change in your habits in
your mindset and in your you don't have
to stay stuck
when you come up with a great idea that
in your heart you know this is the thing
that I want to do and then almost
instantly all the negative voices come
in your head as to why you can't do it
and why someone like you will never be
able to do this thing
you're stuck can keeps you small keeps
you frustrated keeps you knowing that
you're capable of more and being too
afraid to go take the action and until
you can break that pattern of negative
self-talk
nothing will happen
so we're gonna fix that in this video I
think as soon as we come up with ideas
it's not even our friends it's not even
the people around us it's us it's us
telling ourselves that we suck that we
can't do it that we're not good enough
that we're not capable that it's not
going to happen
we'd land into
procrastination mode and you can call
yourself a perfectionist it has to be
perfect
but perfectionism is still just fear
just fear just fear that you're not good
enough feel that it won't work out fear
of being seen fear of not being seen
and it keeps you stuck
when I procrastinate on things even like
making videos
yeah I've made I don't know how many
twelve thousand thirteen thousand
fourteen thousand videos some crazy
number of videos and yet every time
before I sit down to make the videos I
procrastinate a little bit
in today's filming session I'm here at
my wife's Acupuncture Clinic she's
inside getting her acupuncture done I
joined her sitting in the car and it
probably took me
15 minutes
to get into
The Zone I know I'm gonna make the
videos I've developed the identity that
I'm gonna get get it done but I'm I'm
worried I want I want the videos to be
good I wanted I don't want to embarrass
myself don't want to let myself down
don't want to let you down if you're
disappointing people is my my biggest
fear I don't want you to feel like this
is wasting your time ever had these
thoughts you know he's like you want to
do something and then you want it to be
good and you don't want to disappoint
people and so you him when you ha and
you procrastinate and then and then all
of a sudden the day is gone you haven't
done anything you know has that happened
so I try to keep it the 10 minutes 15
minutes today's a little longer I'd
usually be like five ten minutes took a
little bit longer 15 minutes today to
get into
to get into the zone and you know what
happened the next thought was
what if I just check uh check and see
how my team is doing and and
because I want to feel valuable and
because I want to feel like I'm doing
something productive I want to get out
of the discomfort of not filming videos
and go check in on my team because that
would make me feel more productive like
no no no no
sit with it we're gonna we gotta change
it we gotta go we gotta make some
content you're gonna do this and make
that first video so even for me even for
someone who's done
five figures of videos
every time I I sit in front of the
camera to make a video the first one I
procrastinate I sit on it because I'm
afraid
and I don't want to disappoint people so
it's totally normal so if you feel like
whatever the thing is that you want to
do
you know you're capable of it you know
in your heart that it's something that
you want to create and then for some
reason you keep stopping you keep
procrastinating you keep staying stuck
that's normal you're not there's nothing
wrong with you it's not abnormal it's
100 everybody goes through it
the difference is how quickly can you
shift how can you get unstuck because
most people just stay stuck they stay
constipated
like all this all the stuff that has to
come out that's just not coming out
constipated
you stay stuck so how do you do it how
do you shift it here are a couple things
that helped me that I hope can help you
number one is is floss the first tooth
take immediate momentum you think about
flossing
it's you know people don't want to floss
I mean I floss I've built the habit of
flossing twice a day most people don't
floss and the concept is just floss one
tooth and once you floss one tooth
you'll floss the rats probably right
just get your running shoes on and go
for a walk and once you're walking
you'll probably do more than you know
the two minutes that you set yourself
into mind like just do two minutes so
for me is just make the first video
come on Evan just record the first video
so I recorded the first video and now
this is my second video in my filming
session and I'm already feeling better
it's like we're going we're vibing yeah
let's do this isn't
it come on
just get going just just go it's so much
easier to keep the momentum going once
you've built some momentum the hardest
step is the first step the hardest step
is just building that initial momentum
at the beginning once you get going it's
a lot easier to keep going so just start
don't don't make it some big thing don't
make it some giant Endeavor that you
have to go off and Chase it's nice to
have big goals and big Ambitions and Big
Dreams but sometimes they're too big and
then you feel like you can't do it and
you need venture capital and you need a
team you need all sorts of things before
you can do anything on it it's great to
have that big goal and what are you
gonna do today
to build some kind of momentum
and once you start building that
momentum it's just so much so much so
much so much easier so the challenge for
today is just just find one small simple
easy way to get started that it doesn't
have to be amazing it doesn't have to be
great it's just the first step once you
get your first step it's so much easier
to take the second so that's why just
start building some immediate momentum
number two is change your state
one of the reasons why I like filming in
the car people ask why are you always
filming in your car I like I like being
out I like I like being out of the place
out of my home I like I like energy I
like nature I like being able to see
trees and and sunshine and have people
around you know I like I like that it
changes my state it's it makes it a lot
easier for me to go off and film when
I'm by myself so it's not just
um me talking to the camera if
more conversational I don't know it's
all it's all just a a head game
but it feels more I feel like I'm
talking to a friend hello
how you doing I'm Evan it feels it feels
more conversational and natural for me I
like having the sun on my face you know
it just feels better and so changing
your state can be a good way if you're
in a
wherever you're at you know think
whether you're in your bed or in your
car or you're in your office or the
dining room table you know change your
state move around get up
you want to change the negative thoughts
start moving get up doesn't have to go
work out or do you know 100 jumping
jacks just get up and even get in some
fresh air getting out of the space that
you're thinking negatively in really
helps just changing your physical
location really really really really
helps I promise you have you ever had a
uh you're thinking really negatively
um you're procrastinating you're feeling
down and then you go for a walk and you
feel better or even just change your
room where you go to a different part of
the house or you go for a drive and then
you feel better like changing the
physical environment can really help you
get out of that funk that you're in
where while you're in that space you're
feeling
stuck and you can't move so change your
physical environment one little bonus to
that is music music I should have done
that today music is
the fastest way to change your state so
while I was sitting here in the car for
15 minutes procrastinating making these
videos instead of thinking hey I should
go and check in on my team and see how
they're doing underneath like logically
that makes sense like how's my team
doing I'm being a good boss you know
good manager a good friend I should
check in on them see how they're doing
it's going to move my goals forward of
course because if they're waiting on me
for something right logically all that
makes sense underneath it is just again
the fear that my videos won't be good
enough so I need to feel productive I
need to feel value valuable to myself I
need to feel worthy so I'm going to
spend my time there instead of making
videos right I should have put on music
when that was happening
instead of going to check out my team
which I didn't do but wanted to
uh I should have put on some music like
put on some music that makes you move
and you don't have to be the most
expressive dancer or singer just
anything that would get your head bobbin
or your foot tapping or your knee
bouncing just songs that make you come
alive and there's no one Perfect song
but whatever song gets you in the zone
even if you're feeling really low you'll
find yourself like having energy and
moving and it changes your state the
whole point is just to get on stock and
to start building some momentum towards
what you say is what you want to do
right so music is a fast way to change
your state and then number three is I
would say have play bigger triggers and
play bigger triggers are the things in
your environment that remind you of who
you want to be
things that you could put up the the
reminders on your cell phone background
on your desktop background the artwork
on your wall the things that you could
put in your life to remind you of who
you want to be so I'll share a couple
from my example in my office I have five
pictures on the wall and they all tell a
different story remind me of who I want
to be I've got Steve Jobs on the wall
who reminds me to be a Visionary I've
got epginini on the wall who's my
favorite entrepreneur of all time and he
reminds me to to believe in
um in the little guy and what I'm trying
to do I've got my parents on the wall
who remind me to believe in myself I've
got Howard Schultz on the wall who
reminds me to stand for something
important they've got Kanye on the wall
to remind me that the time is now that I
have to go do something now to be the
greatest me and
those pictures I picked with intention
and when I walk into my office they're
there and they remind me and I don't
have to do anything you know you set it
up once and it reminds me it reminds you
of who you want to be I walk in the
office there's my parents looking back
at me and telling me to believe in
myself the clothes that you wear right I
wear I wear this is my believe hoodie I
feel like I'm Batman I tell myself when
I put this on I'm Batman I'm a superhero
going to work fighting
the crime of lack of belief
she's like you're always wearing you're
always on brand you're always wearing
your hoodies like it's not just it's not
just when I show up to make videos this
is this is this is what I wear because
I'm a I'm a superhero going to work and
when I put this on in the morning it's
like I'm I'm I'm Batman going to work or
uh uh you know police officer going to
work it's like this is this is what I do
and
and I'm a lot more for me
productive and ambitious and bold when
I'm wearing this compared to when I'm in
my pajamas
and so there's a conscious choice to say
okay what do I want to wear and so the
artwork on my wall the background on my
cell phone the computer screen
background the the things that I wear
right play bigger triggers
that use ideally just set it up once
and then it reminds you it's okay there
it is there's my trigger again there
there it is this is who I want to be
this is who I want to be this is who I
want to be I'm around the things that
make me remember what I'm trying to do
because your brain will trick you to
stay small your brain will trick you to
stay stuck your brain will trick you to
say yeah you you can't do that and
here's all the reasons why
and you believe those reasons you
believe those reasons you are really
you're just afraid I'm just afraid I'm
afraid that we're not good enough we're
afraid they're going to be judged we're
afraid of disappointing people we're
afraid of not being loved we're afraid
that
we're going to be seen and gonna be made
fun of you know we're just afraid at the
end of the day you me everybody we're
just we're just afraid that the reason
why you're stuck is you're afraid and so
when you can learn to catch those
feelings
and when you can learn to uncover those
feelings and switch them say you know
what
I'm going to change my environment I'm
going to change my state I'm going to
change what I'm listening to I'm going
to change what I'm wearing I'm going to
change my mind and I'm going to go do
the thing to start building momentum
because the only thing you're missing is
momentum the only thing you're missing
is momentum you've got a great heart a
great Soul a great idea your idea is
worthy you're doing it for the right
reasons you want to serve you can do
this you can be in a totally different
place in 6 months and 12 months you can
it's possible you can your mission is
worthy and Noble and should happen and
you're the one to do it you you're the
one to do it
and it's not that you're not good enough
and it's not that you're not capable and
it's not that you can't do it at some
point you just don't have the momentum
momentum you just missing momentum
and so the next time you feel stuck
procrastinating not good enough
know that you can do it
and that all you need to do is take that
first step great ideas flow through you
teach yourself to learn to understand to
feel that great ideas flow through you
that when you are feeling bold powerful
courageous ambitious an idea comes to
you that is the right perfect idea for
you right now
and don't let your head talk you down
from doing it I think most of us live
small I think I think we're constantly
living small we're so concerned about
our friends telling us that our ideas
suck it's us
it's ourselves it's you telling yourself
that your idea sucks that you can never
do that we feel great one day this is
the entrepreneur roller coaster right
you feel great one day oh my God this is
such a great idea I could go do this
this is amazing and maybe you start
taking some action on it but then what
immediately happens is your head starts
taking over say well you I mean you
can't do that because you you don't have
the school the education the parents the
connections you live in the wrong
country you're the wrong gender race Etc
and then and then it stops
meanwhile dummies are winning off of
your idea with less heart with less
drive with less ambition with less of a
desire to do good they're winning off of
your idea because they went off and did
something while you are stuck
overthinking your idea this is what we
do this is what entrepreneurs especially
the the heart
centered ones do
stock constantly over analyzing
overthinking and stuck in the mud
instead of actually creating and the way
to go through it is to trust in your
ideas
if you're concerned that that's too
egotistical like oh I'm so great I got
these great ideas great take yourself
out of the equation
trust that the idea came from somewhere
and it was given to you and it's your
responsibility to birth it into life
it's not even your idea it was given to
you
and then go off and create
one of the things that has really helped
me achieve speed and momentum is
I've learned to not judge the ideas that
come to me
I've just said you know what because I
came up with this idea now I have to go
do something about it and sometimes it
turns into the next great thing and
sometimes it goes nowhere that's okay
right the first top 10 video I ever made
on my channel was on Kanye West and he's
behind me on the wall there he is Kanye
West
because my friend
made a blog post about Kanye uh that was
in a negative light and so I wanted to
make it positive say Hey you can learn
from him and so I made a top 10 video on
Kanye West just to show my friend I had
other things planned today shut that all
down just to make this one video just to
show my friend with no plan of this is
gonna be my next big idea right people
say well how did you know I didn't know
I got an idea and I did something about
it
I'm not that smart to be able to project
10 years forward and say Here's Where
the world is going right maybe I can
leave that to Elon Musk I'm not that
smart
but it came to me so I did it and it
turned into something amazing
I've had other ideas that that I started
and didn't go anywhere either the idea
wasn't good enough or or more likely my
energy just kind of faded from it and so
I stopped doing it but at least I gave
it a shot all of these ideas that you've
got you don't know which one's gonna
work out they could all be practically
speaking great ideas what's the best
idea for you I don't know you don't know
either until you start to try it
by taking the immediate action on it
you have to trust in your ideas that
they came to you for a reason are you
supposed to do something about them
so how do we start doing how do you
start taking the action how do you start
getting getting unstuck in your head of
all the stuff that holds us back from
actually creating let me give some Steps
step number one
idea to action
take your brain out of the equation
there's a phrase that when when you're
in your head you're dead like as soon as
you start overthinking something it's
over
you came with the idea you're gonna do
something about it when today
you came with the idea so you're gonna
do something about it when right now
what's your next idea what are you
thinking of right to go do something
about it immediate action take the
because you came up with the idea
therefore you must go do the thing
that's the training you want to give
yourself doesn't mean you have to go and
do some big thing but you have to get
started immediate momentum you want to
start a YouTube channel great you pull
out your phone and you make a video it
doesn't matter what you say it doesn't
matter what the lighting is don't worry
about the sound don't worry about having
a fancy microphone or fancy camera you
pull out your phone you press record and
you say you're starting the channel and
you post that first video
okay but then it's gonna suck great
which leads to point number two expect
to suck at the beginning
why do you expect to be great out of the
gate you will not be great out of the
gate doesn't mean that you suck as a
human just means that your product sucks
but it's your first attempt that's okay
when you try anything you fall when you
get on a bicycle you didn't just ride
right you got a skateboard you didn't
just go
you're gonna suck that's okay that's the
learning process you're gonna learn a
lot more and get better a lot quicker by
actually trying where we're stuck in
learning and researching and planning
and then nothing that ends up getting
created you are wasting your best energy
on planning this is what most this is
what most people do this is what happens
almost all the time you can with an idea
you think it's a great idea
oh my gosh it's such a great idea
great you spend the next day or until
you go to sleep planning researching
preparing
and then you wake up tomorrow and say I
can't do that that's crazy that idea I
had yesterday is crazy I can't do that
who did I think I was to be able to do
that you spent your best energy your
most confident energy your most bold
energy on doing the wrong thing planning
instead of making planning is important
but it's not the first thing you should
do the first thing you do is take some
kind of action some kind of immediate
momentum some kind of commitment
especially to somebody else that you're
going to do something
so if you want to start a YouTube
channel you take out your phone and say
hi I'm going to start my YouTube channel
I don't know what I'm going to make
content of I'm really nervous but I've
been putting this off for five years and
I'm tired of putting things off so I
don't know join my journey and let's see
how it goes great post
and as you start making
you're gonna get better at it your first
thing is supposed to suck if you're
going to get started you're going to
start making YouTube videos as an
example and your first video is amazing
then you actually suck then you waited
too long your first version of whatever
you do should be terrible that's okay
so Step One is listen to the ideas trust
the ideas they are right for you because
they came to you you got to do something
about it take immediate action
and in Step number two is expect to suck
reduce the burden of expectation on
yourself that you have to be great from
the start as kids we do this right we
start we try we fail we laugh hahaha and
as adults all of a sudden we're afraid
to do anything
and what you do is just slide into more
of your comfort zone and more your
comfort zone more of your comfort zone
more of your comfort zone and then
realize why do I hate my life so much
because you're doing the same thing
every day because you're afraid to
Branch out a little bit
just expect to suck
reduce that burden that you have to be
amazing
and if you keep practicing you keep
loving it you keep building it guess
what you're gonna get great at it
doesn't have to take a decade this hacks
his shortcuts model success you'll get
there faster
but you still have to do the journey and
step one of the journey is the most
important step and is also the most
painful step that it's gonna suck
amazing every time you suck at something
at the start pat yourself on the back
you did a good job
step number three
and this is just the caveat is pay
attention to your energy when you come
up with ideas okay I'm assuming you're
in a positive bold ambitious confident
courageous State when you are feeling a
positive emotion the ideas that flow
through you are the right ideas for you
however when you're feeling negative low
you're feeling judgmental you're feeling
anger you're feeling depression you're
feeling rage you're you're upset that
somebody else is having success when
you're in a negative mindset
the ideas that come to you are not the
one ones for you those are the ones to
sit on right like I'm gonna show her I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this thing to him I'm
gonna I'm gonna get my Revenge by doing
that okay let those are the ideas to sit
on and it's funny because those are the
ideas we usually act on
the spontaneous ideas that come to you
that are negative you're more likely to
act on than the spontaneous ones that
come to you that are positive
you're more likely to send that nasty
text or leave that negative review or do
that negative thing instead of the
positive one and so if you're in a
negative state of mind that's when it's
worth waiting till tomorrow you know if
tomorrow you think it's the right call
okay then then let's think about it but
not in the moment don't do the negative
ones in the moment but if it's positive
if you just came back from a seminar or
you're watching this video or you're
around amazing humans and you get these
great ideas those are the ones that you
need to take some immediate action on
you have amazing ideas
you have a a heart and a soul that wants
a serve that wants to help that wants to
contribute that wants to not just fill
your pockets and fill your bank account
but also contribute and help other
people you know you've got something
much bigger inside you
but it does not come out
unless you start to listen to those
ideas and start to do something about
them
so the next time an idea comes to you
maybe you got one right now
maybe something's flowing through you
right now
learn to trust that idea tell yourself
that great ideas flow through you
that you need to take some immediate
action on it and that it's gonna suck at
the beginning and that's the best and
that's how you learn because if you kept
doing that do that for three months do
that for six months do that for 12
months
the amount of amazing things you're
going to help create for yourself for
your family for your community for the
world
is going to be just outstanding and I
can't wait to see what you end up making
the reason why you're not following
through is because you're doing it alone
when you wake up and you feel like you
are by yourself you are all alone you
have no Community you're not
collaborating you're not doing this with
anybody else
it's just
massively difficult to follow through
still possible absolutely but this is
the life of an entrepreneur this is why
so many great entrepreneurs don't follow
through and it
breaks my heart because
You've Got Talent you've got a desire to
serve and the help and you know you have
a story that matters and you're just not
as consistent as you know you could be
and it's not that you suck it's just
that you're doing it alone this is
something I've struggled with
in terms of being a great resource for
people because I actually have a very
low Community need I think the journey
that I went through is
almost impossible to model
because I just woke up every day and I
still made videos and I still make
content and I did it by myself and it's
not prescriptive it's really difficult
to
do it exactly the way that I did most
people need more Community than me I
still need it
but I have a really low maybe it's just
introverted or or uh what it whatever
but I just don't need it as much as most
people
you probably need more Community you
probably are not following through
because you feel isolated and alone and
the great promise of Entrepreneurship is
freedom right like you don't have to
have a boss you don't get to you don't
have to have employees that you hate or
people on your team who you hate you get
to pick everything you want but then to
go from having a job where you have
Community even if it even if you didn't
enjoy the work you were doing which you
got from the job if you've had one is
community that you had co-workers and
you had some people who you did like and
you had people to go to lunch with and
you you know you had just human
connection every day where as an
entrepreneur you don't have that
nearly as much or at all
and so it's very lonely
and it's really hard to do great work
when when you're lonely
so what's the solution
no you're great yeah you just tore my
heart open Evan now what do I do how do
I fix it well first it's just
recognizing that that is a problem you
know first is recognizing that there's
nothing wrong with you there's nothing
wrong with you you're amazing the only
problem is you just don't have anybody
that you're collaborating with that
you're doing this by yourself so the
answer is we need to now go and find
other people to collaborate with so one
recognizing that this is a problem and
you need to fix it two is in finding a
group that you can be a part of and what
we tend to do as entrepreneurs is lead
we want to lead we want to create groups
we want to build we want to make
oh
I would actually advocate for joining a
group
one you don't need another thing on your
plate to lead you've got enough already
that you have to worry about until when
you're the leader of it it puts you in a
slightly different position where it's
nice just to participate you know it's
nice just to have somebody else be in
charge and you just get to show up
and and be a part of it
so I would look for a community that you
could join
where it's where it's your people it's
people like you who are trying to do
similar things
I look at movement makers as an example
and whether you want to join Movie
Makers or or you know find your own
group amazing but movement makers I
started as a way for me to help train
up and coming thought leaders you know
it was the initial goals like hey I can
only reach I want to tell the world's
biggest problem right people don't
believe in themselves enough not
everybody's going to learn through my
story but they might be able to learn
through yours your message your story
your history your way of looking at it
the thing that you went through I
haven't gone through until that by
definition allows you to reach people
that I can't that Tony Robbins can't
that Jay Shetty can't that whoever Oprah
can't right your story can reach people
in a way that others can't and so I want
to give you the skills to be able to go
off and reach those people that's why I
started Movie Makers what I realized
getting through it is the skills alone
Aren't Enough the skills are not the
main reason why people are not following
through
you already have a lot of skills you
know it's not where you want to be but
you have a lot of skills and you have a
lot of Hearts if you take somebody with
a lot of skills and a lot of heart and
they're still not following through
what's the problem
Community you're doing it alone
you're lonely and it's really hard to do
it when you're lonely so I shifted
movement makers to still BS skills and
training and techniques and strategies
and I realized that people are winning
when they connected to each other
and at the start I was doing all the
connection like oh I know this person's
doing this and this person's doing that
and so I should connect those two people
together and I was and that was creating
that's created businesses it's created
podcasts together that's created
opportunities for people but it still
was limited on me connecting people
together where I wanted to make it that
people
would connect to each other without me
and that's what we've ended up doing in
Movie Makers one of the things I'm most
proud of
is we started a challenge and again
whether I don't care if you join Movie
Makers or not great to have you but this
concept you can apply to your business
we started a challenge where
I was giving people the tactics and
telling them what to do and that they
still weren't doing a follow through and
the follow-through would be making
content making videos right you want to
be a thought leader you got to get your
message out there
so I started a challenge and we started
the first one I think back in October so
now we're into our fifth challenge or so
where here's a challenge you have to
make one video
one lead magnet and three collaboration
videos around the theme
the theme might be momentum or impact or
believe or belong
um we pick a different theme every month
but something everybody can talk to
right the theme was impact you can talk
the impact within the thing that you do
and by forcing them to collaborate with
three other people in the group
it really led to a situation where one
plus one equals a thousand
because
by forcing yourself to show up for
somebody else
it made sure that you followed through
where all of a sudden now people who who
hadn't made a single video who might
have been a movie makers for three
months and still never made a video now
they're making their first videos now
they're making the first lead magnets
now they're making their first solo
videos suddenly they have
some follow-through
and suddenly the fears and the excuses
will weigh because they're connected to
other people when you're doing something
with somebody else there's energy there
there's momentum there and you're much
more likely to follow through
so you have to go and get a tribe
find people who are like you who have a
similar Mission if you look at mover
makers
everybody's mission is is different in
the sense that they're trying to serve
different people but everybody's
connected in that we want to have an
impact we have a story that matters and
we want to share it with the world
that's everybody in the group
the types of people trying to reach are
different and so when you are
by yourself you're the only one in your
family trying to do what you do you're
the one pouring into other people right
you're probably the most happy
optimistic positive person you're
encouraging the people around you you're
pouring into their cups great keep doing
that but who's helping you with that
when you feel low when you feel down
when you feel not worthy when you feel
not good enough who's pouring in you
they say hey let's go do this thing
together
nobody right your friends maybe I mean
if you're lucky and you have some great
friends might be empathetic might be
encouraging in you but they're not doing
the thing that you're doing they don't
understand what you're going through
they could they could give you some
words of affirmation and encouragement
but they don't know how to actually help
where if you're going through a journey
with somebody else with a group of
people you're just much more likely to
follow through
and feel connected
and feel special and feel like you
matter
so Step One is recognize that there's
nothing wrong with you
you're amazing you've got the heart
you've got the dream you've got the the
ability to serve
on step two is then to go find your
tribe go find people who are like you
who you see on your calendar and you're
excited to go meet with them and connect
whether it's Movie Makers or something
totally separate
but don't do this alone
if you could make one change this year
for the next 12 months
to have a significant impact on the
growth of your journey
commit to just not doing this by
yourself
and watch everything in your life get
better
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there you are what you consistently
think about whether you think you'll win
or lose you're right it's a challenge I
think a lot of us face we are stuck in
our head in our mind telling ourselves
why we can't do something why we're not